Do you have any thoughts or info thoughts about Leia Troll making them be 17 Africa seeds?
So you get a boat of right now. That's what I'm doing. Yep. Yeah, just kidding. So of course, I've lots of thoughts about it and I write about it in my book
and have posts about it
So these 17 is a very potent
oxidizing agent for cancer. So in my latest blog post about heartic ed oxidative stress to kill cancer, I talk about
core different nutrients, those dependently affected cancer cells can't go excited to see selenium.
What else do I write about?
Invited to be built to talk to treat us and
and melatonin. Well, Leia Troll, it's don't have to be those dependent for Leia Troll to be an oxidizing agent.
So that's how these 17 works. It's an oxidizing agent. So you know, we always think oxidizing agents are bad. Well, it's all about balance and oxidizing agents are fairly beneficial.
Your body makes oxidizing agents, it makes reactive oxygen and reactants and species in the presence of stress, whether it's microbial stress meeting that we have an infection or emotional stress, you develop
active oxygen species for the purpose of killing microbes and has other functions in your body too. And you keep that in balance with your antioxidant system intercellular.
Well, these 17 is an oxidizing agent similar to chemo is an oxidizing agent similar to those dependent different nutrients that are in normal doses, antioxidants.
So they can be very great killers of cancer. So read that post.
If you really feel led to use the 17, I think the best product on the market is the apricot power brand we have it in our store.
I'm just going to go slow on it. It's not ghost dependent upon its function.
It is an oxidizing agent even at 100 milligrams a day. But the dose dependency on being 17 is based upon its effective killing.
I don't know how fast the cancer is growing. So cancer is growing quickly, then you use a higher dose sequence when we slowly didn't use a lesser dose or use it.
From a perspective of just preventative, that could actually be done too.
So most of the nutrients like these 17 other oxidizing agents tend not to damage healthy cells, unless you're taking high doses.
So the high doses. So these 17 comes in 100 milligram capsules and 500 milligram capsules.
So high dosage partly depends on the weight of the person, but for a person who's a hundred and 50 pounds, three, 500 milligram capsules, a 50 hundred milligram capsules would be.
And again, how bad the cancer is and how long you're using the stoves would be a pretty normal dose to take more of a long term dose can even do these 17 intravenous and a much higher dose.
But of course that's spaced out. You're not doing it every day and you're not doing it. You don't want to turn. So you're just trying to knock down the cancer quickly with that.